ja gegenoffensive so das wort der stunde
in der ukraine denn die ukrainische
armee hat nach ihrer gegen offensive im
süden der region seit gestern eine
weitere gegen offensive im osten landes
des landes in der region aktiv gestartet
wir schauen uns das ganze auf der karte
an besetzt sind vor allem noch die
südlichen und östlichen teile der
ukraine hier im süden trassen etwa seit
einer woche eine gegenoffensive der
ukrainischen armee die immer mehr an
fahrt aufnimmt und hier im osten in
reaktiv eine überraschungs offensive die
erst gestern begonnen wurde und dort
extremer erfolge wird sang erzielt hat
wir schauen uns das ganze an wir hatten
über die stadt wie sie kopie ja schon
gesprochen eine erste stadt die ukraine
erobert hat und man sieht jetzt hier ja
doch relativ ruhige ukrainische soldaten
die laufen nicht fahren laufen weil sie
eben kaum vor allem aus deutschland
gelieferten fahrzeuge haben diese
bräuchte aber man sieht eben außenrum
einfach eine ganz normale stadt eine
entvölkerte stadt von den russischen
autoren aber eben einen staat sie
weiterhin existiert und die
zurückerobert werden konnte physik opel
ja ehemals um die 6000 einwohner kaum
jemand davon dass übrig aber zumindest
die russischen invasoren boden hier
verdrängt und wir sehen die ukraine
feiern und die ukraine weitere gen süden
richtung krim im weitesten sinne
vorrücken
novus neske eine weitere stadt dort in
der nähe relativ kleine stadt ungefähr
1000 einwohner hatte die vor beginn des
krieges auch hier wurde die ukrainische
flagge gehisst in den letzten tagen man
sieht dass hier das wird natürlich von
den ukrainern auch zelebriert dass sie
auf eine der soldat trägt hier auf eine
schule kriegt von einer anderen soldat
die fahne und dann wird sie eben über
der stadt gehisst die schule auch hier
wieder wichtig weil es das größte
gebäude einfach ist und weil wir sicher
sein können wenn die ukraine auf der
schule sind wir sehen uns sonst relativ
kleine häuser immer so einfamilienhäuser
außen rum dann ist offenbar der ganze
ort auch in schussweite zu den russen
unter ukrainischer kontrolle sonst
könnten ukrainer natürlich nicht ihre
flagge hier oben hissen
sonst wollen uns das ganze auf der karte
ansehen und wir sehen mittlerweile auch
auf der karte diese gegenoffensive
nennen wir sehen hier das hier ein
erster ihren schnitt wenn man so möchte
in die russische front passiert ist man
versucht die weiter richtung die neb
vorzubringen und wiese kopie ja wir
hatten eben darüber gesprochen ist hier
im norden auch hier ein weiterer
einschnitt in die russische front zu
sehen und von dort versucht man weiter
nach
südwesten vorzudringen das also im süden
des landes doch nicht nur im süden des
landes auch im osten des landes gibt es
hier eine neue ukrainische offensive und
die hat in der nähe der stadt baghlan
stattgefunden bei der klima damit hätten
die russen offenbar nicht gerechnet
befindet sich hier zwischen kreativ und
donetzk so etwa auf halber höhe und dort
seit gestern eine ukrainische offensive
und dort wurde eine wichtige autobahn
abgeschnitten wir sehen dass hier heute
morgen ukrainische einheiten leichte
schnelle einheiten die hier vorrücken
die russen vollständig überrascht haben
und wir sehen hier eine
autobahntankstelle hier recht ist ein tv
turm und die ukraine haben offenbar die
autobahn dort erobert und habe neben
ballack lief von koblenz keine ganz
großen statt einer stadt die auch von
russland beherrscht wird abgeschnitten
ballack wird wohl noch von den russen
gehalten im gegensatz zu fünf stehen aus
warum die bereits erobert wurden von den
ukrainern aber in ballack hier sind die
russischen einheiten abgeschnitten und
kommen da auch aktuell nicht mehr weg
wir wollen es noch ein letztes video
ansehen und das sieht erstmal ziemlich
brutal aus ist es aber überhaupt nicht
denn dieses video hier wir sehen das
wurde am ersten september von russischen
accounts veröffentlicht angeblich ist
hier zu sehen ukrainische getöteter
soldaten bei einem angriff auf das
atomkraftwerk von innerrhoder wir
erinnern uns die in die iaeo leute sind
hingekommen am ersten september und die
russen haben behauptet 60 ukrainische
soldaten hätten hier den apple überquert
und hätten versucht das ist
atomkraftwerk zu besetzen und wie sie
sagten die inspektoren als geiseln zu
nehmen dieses video wurde in teilen
veröffentlicht aber was nicht
veröffentlicht wurde sind die letzten
fünf sekunden und da sind wir gleich wir
sehen also überall angeblich die tote
ukrainischer soldaten aber wir sehen uns
das ganze mal an bis zum ende und sehen
was in letzten fünf sekunden passiert
die toten erwachen die angeblichen toten
ukrainischen soldaten stehen plötzlich
alle auf allen geht es wieder gut wir
sehen uns jetzt hier gleich jetzt sagte
entwarnung ihr könnt alle aufstehen hier
steht jemand auf da steht jemand auf da
steht jemand auf alle bewegen sich auch
der jetzt wieder aufgestanden plötzlich
geht es einen soldaten wieder gut sie
können widerstehen oh wunder es waren
überhaupt gar keine ukraine es war ein
russischer soldaten wie sich den
ukrainische uniform reingepresst haben
und dann tot gespielt haben um eben
diesen propagandafilm zu erzeugen um zu
erzeugen dass die karine hier die
eu-mission aufhalten möchte oder wie
auch immer aufhalten wollte aber die
russen sie geschlagen hätten das also
ein propagandavideo der schlimmsten art
großen die tote ukraine spielen und
danach wieder aufstehen so also der gang
des krieges 7 6 monate nach beginn
[Musik]